Speaker 1: All right, so I think something
is going on this week from the standpoint
of the former president, Donald Trump and
Trump supporters, I want to go over it with
you right now.
As many of you might remember, August was
supposedly a very important month for many
Trump supporters when Donald Trump was supposedly
going to be reinstated.
Of course, it's not going to happen, but Donald
Trump is going to be speaking at a rally in
Cullman, Alabama, this Saturday after being
basically missing from from the public in
any real way for about a month and in the
lead up to this rally on Saturday at which
now listen to this.
There are some Trump supporters who believe
Trump will be reinstated at the rally in Alabama
Saturday.
I mean, just you know, we don't even have
to delve into that.
But Donald Trump has done a couple of interviews
in the last couple of days with Sean Hannity,
which we'll look at first, and then with Maria
Bartiromo, which we will look at second this
first interview.
I really don't know what to make of this.
Donald Trump looks like he either just woke
up, people emailed me saying Trump actually
seemed senile in this interview.
Trump is rumpled.
He's disheveled.
His right eye is again almost completely swollen
shut, which seems to be pretty common.
Now, in the interviews, he just looks like
he woke up as the interview was starting and
started answering the first question, which
made very little sense.
Let's just jump right in here.
Speaker 4: Well, it's good to be with you,
but it's a terrible time for our country.
I don't think in all of the years our country
has ever been so humiliated, I don't know
when you call it a military defeat or a psychological
defeat.
There's never been anything like what's happened
here.
Speaker 1: Now, if you're wondering what the
hell is he talking about?
He's talking about leaving Afghanistan, which
is exactly what he planned to do.
He just ran out of time to do it.
Speaker 4: So you can go back to Jimmy Carter
with the hostages.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So the hostages were definitely something
that Trump looked at very strongly.
That right eye almost swollen shut, Trump
making absolutely no sense.
And then it goes from strange optics to strange
substance, with Trump claiming that the Taliban
has been fighting for a thousand years.
The Taliban was formed in 1994.
What is the what is this guy talking about?
Speaker 4: Oh, we did a terrible thing.
But think of what's happening now.
I've heard as many as 40 thousand Americans
and the Taliban, good fighters.
I will tell you, they're good fighters who
have to give them credit for that.
They've been fighting for a thousand years.
That's what they do, is they fight the Taliban.
Speaker 1: So praising the Taliban.
But also a thousand years,
Speaker 4: Sabban has circled the airport
and who knows if they're going to treat us
like, you know, all of them.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So making very, very little sense then, as
if that's not weird enough in the next segment.
This is a 90 second Trump rant related to
the criticisms of how Trump planned to do
the same thing Biden did in Afghanistan.
But he's incoherent and he's slurring.
And I can't tell what point he's trying to
make,
Speaker 4: as I thought it would maybe run
through bureaucracy.
It doesn't you need somebody up there that
they're going to respect.
So when they say, oh, he talk to the Taliban,
you remember they were criticized.
I mean, they criticize me when I talk to Kim
Jong un.
Well, President Biden told me it's the single
biggest problem we have.
I said, have you ever called him?
Have you?
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, the criticism of
his conversation with Kim Jong un was Trump
thought that the concessions Kim Jong un made
mattered, that they had any substance behind
them when they're the same concessions that
North Korean leaders have been pretending
to make to the U.S. for 40 years and other
presidents know not to fall for them.
Trump fell for it.
That was the criticism.
Speaker 4: Trump No, I haven't.
He did try, but he was not it was not receptive
on the other side.
But it was receptive is with me now.
We were supposed to have a war and probably
a very big nuclear war.
I get along with him.
Great.
And I got along with him.
He doesn't like Biden much, I'll tell you
that.
Speaker 1: But I guess it's about the supposedly
this is about Afghanistan along with him.
Speaker 4: Great.
And we had no problems.
You remember that?
It was we were very slow.
Remember the big button versus the little
button and the whole thing.
I just we get along great.
We had a very good relationship.
We met.
We got no credit for that one.
No problem.
Speaker 1: Well, he accomplished nothing,
Speaker 4: by the way.
South Korea got them to pay billions of dollars.
Billions.
We're protecting South Korea.
They're very wealthy.
They built the ships.
They built the televisions, they built.
They do everything.
They're very rich.
They were paying us nothing.
I got them to pay billions and billions of
dollars because we're protecting them from
North Korea.
And I had a very good relations.
Speaker 1: OK, so supposedly that was about
Afghanistan.
But then he's talking about Kim Jong un and
all sorts.
They're just completely free.
It's free association.
It it's almost Freudian in nature where the
interviewer.
Yeah, the whole thing.
Hannity is asking questions.
But he would almost get the same stuff if
he took a Freudian approach where the psychotherapist
says almost nothing and like doesn't even
steer the conversation at all.
OK, we'll continue.
Then the vaccine comes up and Trump says,
yeah, the vaccine is good, but freedom is
important.
And, you know, if you want, wear your mask.
But, yeah, freedom is important.
Speaker 4: But I would I would love people
to take the vaccine.
In the meantime, wear your mask if you want,
but if you want again, you want your freedoms,
you have to have your freedoms.
Right.
Speaker 1: So, yeah, I mean, I guess all else
being equal.
Sure.
Get vaccinated.
But freedom and you know, if you want wear
your mask.
But freedom, the freedom part is really, really
important.
And then Donald Trump says now that I genuinely
don't understand this, it seems that Hannity
asks Trump, what would you do if you were
president right now?
And Trump seems to say, I can't tell you if
I'm running because of campaign finance.
I've watched this clip five times.
I think that that's what happened.
See if you can figure it out.
Speaker 4: You considering a run again in
twenty, twenty four.
I'll let you answer it any way you want, but
I'll go back to our original question.
Speaker 1: So Hannity mentions the twenty
four, but then he goes to a question.
Now that we
Speaker 4: have all these Americans behind
enemy lines, do you have in the 45 seconds
we have left, what what would you do now to
help that with that specific situation?
So because the campaign finance laws are extremely
complicated and unbelievably stupid, I'm actually
not allowed to answer that question.
Can you believe it?
I'd love to answer it, but let me put it this
way.
I think you'll be happy.
And I think a lot of our
Speaker 1: now that's not true.
Trump Trump can say whether his intention
is to run or not, what he may be referring
to in his weird free association, cloud nine
sort of way is that there may be additional
scrutiny upon all the money being donated
to him if he were to say that he's running.
But Trump is free to tell us if he intends
to run or not.
It was weird that he keeps repeating that.
OK, now we get, I guess, to the answer about
what would he do?
Speaker 4: Friends would be very happy, but
I'm not actually allowed to answer it.
It makes it very difficult if I do.
So, people, you're going to be happy because
I love this country and I hate to see what's
happening.
Would you be willing to.
Speaker 1: OK, so Trump won't tell us what
he would do and he also won't tell us whether
he's running.
This man is worshiped by tens of millions
of Americans.
And that's a really, really scary thought.
So that was on Hannity, the bizarre, rumpled,
crumpled, disheveled, swollen interview.
And all of this leading up to this rally he's
doing on Saturday.
Let's go next to his interview yesterday with
Fox host Maria Bartiromo.